[Music]
talk about a Friday news dump you got a
barrage of bad news for the Biden family
coming on three fronts today first is
the stunning Twist of a hunter's
sweetheart deal heard around the world
you got attorney general Merrick Garland
appointing Federal prosecutor and
Delaware U.S attorney David Weiss as
special counsel in the probe of
President Biden's son Hunter
upon considering his request as well as
the extraordinary circumstances relating
to this matter I have concluded that it
is in the public interest to appoint him
as special counsel
this appointment confirms my commitment
to provide Mr Weiss all the resources he
requests
it also reaffirms that Mr Weiss has the
authority he needs to conduct a thorough
investigation and to continue to take
the steps he deems appropriate
independently based only on the facts
and the law all right let's try to break
this down keep this in mind David Weiss
is the same prosecutor who cooked up the
original sweetheart deal that Hunter
kind of blew up you know a judge kind of
blew it up as we take a closer look and
they realize it's ridiculous and it
doesn't involve any of his foreign
business dealing so his lawyers decided
they didn't want the deal and now we are
learning that Federal prosecutors expect
Hunters tax and gun trout to go to trial
after a new plea deal completely unravel
so as for the big guy's involvement in
the new Hunter special counsel the doj
is declining to comment on whether
President Biden himself is under
investigation so for now we're just
gonna have to take Joe at his word that
he never talk shop with Hunter
I've never discussed my business or
their business my sons or daughters I've
never spoken to my son about his
overseas I have never discussed with my
son or my brother or anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses
and I know you'd have a lousy question
well what do you it's why is that a
lousy question thank you because it's
not true
thank you Mr President
Republicans ripping into the decision to
appoint whites a special counsel house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy warning it better
not quote obstruct Congressional
investigations into potential Biden
family corruption and other lawmakers
agree
this was a political decision not a
legal decision they're trying to put out
a fire and they just poured gasoline on
it nobody in their right mind believes
that making him a special counsel Mr
Weiss cleans up the mess that's been
created it's about time on the other
hand I have some question about Weiss
doing it this is attempt to whitewash
the Biden family corruption I am very
fearful that appointing the special
counsel is just an attempt to Stonewall
congress's investigation of the Biden
family and finally team Biden is said to
be in talks with his classified doc
special counsel to have Joe be
personally interviewed which you may
remember involves the president leaving
our nation's Secrets stashed in the
garage next to his Corvette amongst
other places judge your reaction to the
presser that brought us to this place to
have a special prosecutor be the same
David Weiss as the guy that's looked
into this for years
you know it's kind of hard to to convey
my feelings because I am furious number
one stop laughing Lauren number one okay
this guy Weiss is compromised he is
untruthful he is not capable of being a
special counsel number one is special
counsel should be from outside the
government down someone inside the
government because this is a conflict of
interest case okay but more importantly
is this David Weiss is the one who put
together the plea deal that was rejected
by a federal judge that plea deal was
not only a sweetheart deal it was
corrupt what it did was it gave Hunter
Biden legal immunity in perpetuity that
means for the rest of his life he could
never be charged with a crime now the
amazing part of it is then why slide and
he said but the case is still under
investigation why because he didn't want
the Republican house to investigate so
then Merrick Garland comes out and he
says Tuesday a why said he wants to be a
special counsel why wise finish this
investigation why said he had all the
power that he needed he told Jim Jordan
that in June so why today does he need a
special counsel plus he wanted to bathe
him in legal immunity and it gets even
better than this the fact is that this
plea deal not only prevented anyone from
going forward but the same guy who tries
to pull the wool over the American
people's eyes and the federal judge's
eyes it's a contradiction because now he
is stopping the Congressional
investigation by saying that this case
is still underway preventing Congress
again from interviewing all the players
and let me just say one more thing this
is a good news bad news cycle we hear
about the money from China they never
got any money and all that hogwash and
now all of a sudden we've got a special
counsel this special counsel is not in a
position to do anything based upon the
fact that the most serious crime has
passed the statute of limitations okay
so now which is the five-year statute of
limitation on the tax charges which was
the biggest years with a five million
dollars five million dollars ten million
dollars okay so now they can't comment
on a pending investigation now the
statute of limitations has run on the
most serious crimes now there is no
explanation to Joe Biden's immense
wealth the man is in government his
whole life his wife's a school teacher
give me a break and Weiss is going to
issue a report that says Joe Biden I've
investigated him and he's clean and
there's no question right now that Weiss
is going to begin this investigation
cover for the bidens and say it's all
been handled now is time for the
Republicans to move to impeach Joe Biden
Jessica bad day or good day uh for
Hunter Biden
for Hunter bad day
I I it's ongoing right at what the
expectation was there was a plea deal
yeah we're going to move forward yes and
he should have his day in court and all
of that but I think any day especially
when you think you're heading into the
weekend and you find out that you have a
special counsel is probably not a
fantastic day but the other the good
thing I guess is it seems like it's
going to be a good day for justice and
that he's going to be fully investigated
it seems to me that David Weiss wanted
this now because he wants to be able to
charge him in California and in DC which
he wouldn't have been able to do as a
special prosecutor but the Republicans
yet again are being incredibly Craven
um and contradicting themselves 33
Senate Republicans signed a letter
saying we need a special counsel half of
the GOP conference signed a letter
saying we need a special couns
that's the whole point it isn't actually
the whole point there would be a problem
with anyone except for I don't know John
Eastman and Rudy Giuliani if they were
the special counsel David White is a
trump appointed David nice line
finish he lied to Jim Jordan when he
said he had all the power he needed
because we know from an October 2022
meeting with the FBI the IRS and then in
a contemporaneously made business record
that he said he wasn't given permission
to prosecute the other jurisdictions
in the room David
weisser Point first go ahead oh that's
very generous of you thank you David
Weiss hasn't lied and Merrick Arlene
confirmed it today saying he had all the
powers that he asked for I would have
made him a special counsel but he did
not ask me so obviously something so if
he didn't ask he said he wasn't
interested in getting Justice Jessica
you said this according to the
Whistleblower you may or may not believe
he he was told he could not ask for a
special prosecutor that he wanted it and
The Whistleblower said that he couldn't
do it so exactly admitted under oath
when he was testifying that he made
those requests under the Trump
dojos
you know what else was admitted to under
oath the prosecution as well as defense
when the the court asked was there any
precedent for this deal they both told
the court there was no precedent for
this deal
um Democrats cried when Republicans and
people that are civil Libertarians said
this is not fair this is simply an
outfit when you have Lila Wayne's
attorney Kodak Black Democrats said
Republicans are just making a big deal
about this the court asked them under
oath and the prosecution said
we have nothing so that that's where the
why the deal was destroyed so what we
can expect is this case to continue to
unravel not because Weiss is some
ethical man it's because Weiss
deal got blown up before the courts but
the Democrats can save themselves here
because this is unraveling before the
American people there's one way to do
this either Joe Biden can resign right
now to give Kamala Harris the presidency
and then they can have Gavin Newsom run
for office but the idea that this is
over now this is just beginning now they
could have just conceded they have
talked about what's unfair just as under
law all for years and all of a sudden
when their guy is elected and as it
starts to unravel they don't want equal
justice under the law I just think it's
shame it's just so shame that these
issues were all in play but they were
ignored in 2020. I just real quick this
news uh Joe Biden didn't get close to
the Press no shocker didn't answer any
questions didn't hear any questions
Katie
well the appointment of David Weiss's
special counsel is a total joke when it
comes to credibility of this process I
mean this is the guy as the judge laid
out who decided that they were going to
do this unprecedented plea deal whether
it was the misdemeanor charges at her
five years of Investigation the lack of
fair charges or the diversion program
for a gun charge would be which would be
a felony and many years in prison for
any regular person especially if you've
been through the illegally possessed gun
into a trash can next to a school as Joe
Biden and his girlfriend at the time did
um let's look at how this is going to
look moving forward Hunter Biden the bad
news for him is he's on pre-trial
release because today the justice
department said that they cannot come up
with an agreement to get him a second
plea deal after the first one fell apart
that means he has to be drug tested he
has to get a job he has to inform the
court of when he's going to travel so
they have to get ready for that
I said case will not resolve short of a
trial so the issue now is the fair
problem because the reason the plea deal
fell part is because he was getting
immunity for the plea deal and the Biden
defense team in court said no no we need
immunity for pharah they weren't going
to get it so now the justice department
and the special counsel is in this
position where this is what they have to
investigate now and on its face
especially with the documentation this
week with James Comer oversight
Community chairman 20 million dollars in
foreign money coming to the bidens
hunter Biden being the one facilitating
that money there's a lot of people
politically who've gone to prison for
fair violations on a much smaller scale
and there are big questions about
whether that's going to happen and
because they couldn't come up with the
second plea agreement including the
Pharaoh charges indicates to me that
Hunter Biden is actually kind of worried
about that and for whites to get his
credibility
based on the law he's going to have to
look at that at some point quick answer
we know Comer was going to bring ask the
bidens to come before him like Don
Junior was asked to come before him we
know that Weiss was supposed to come
before the committee does all that stop
yes that's the whole point that's so how
corrupt this is there is nothing about
this that's on the level Jordan's going
to fight that so is Comer according to
his people but we'll see hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else